President Trump will fly back to
Washington this morning after speaking
at the World Economic Forum in Davos
Switzerland he started his day with the
President of Rwanda just two weeks after
reportedly using a vulgar term to
describe some African nations Margaret
Brennan is with the president in Davos
looking at this morning's remarks to
business and political leaders Margaret
good morning good morning well president
Trump will have the final word when he
delivers closing remarks at the World
Economic Forum White House officials say
he will make clear that he supports open
markets and free trade even though he
withdrew the u.s. from one deal with
Asian Pacific countries and is still
threatening to tear up NAFTA the
commander in chief has fashioned himself
as the salesman in chief here at Davos
according CEOs and trying to convince
investors that his america-first
policies are good for global business
when I decided to come to Davos I didn't
think in terms of elitist at localist I
think I thought in terms of lots of
people that want to invest lots of money
he is also trying to reset relationships
with world leaders meeting today with
Rwanda is president Paul Kagame who is
now head of the African Union both
leaders ignored questions about the
president's alleged derogatory reference
to African migrants that caused
diplomatic shockwaves across the
continent in an interview with British
journalist Piers Morgan the president
was asked to apologize for retweeting
anti-muslim videos posted by a far-right
British political activist
if you're telling me that the harpy
people horrible racist people harm
I would certainly apologise if you'd
like me to do that I know nothing about
that
retweeting from Britain first was the
wrong thing to do after prime minister
Theresa May said it was inappropriate to
endorse the hateful videos President
Trump blasted her for not focusing
enough on terrorism yesterday he
insisted the two leaders are getting
along
like in each other a lot not every
financial leader has been receptive to
the president legendary investor and
well-known liberal philanthropist George
Soros called mr. Trump a threat to the
world but Nora largely the reception has
been a warm one for the president and
the officials he brought with him many
of whom have been attending Davos for
years back when they were business
executives all right Margaret Brennan in
Davos thank you